llevan nueve días caminando para tener
la oportunidad de ver al Papa Francisco
exhaustos tras 400 kilómetros de viaje
estos peregrinos sonríen de oreja a
oreja en la capital de Sudán del sur
like decidimos este viaje como caminar
por la paz y no fue fácil decidimos
hacerlo para decir que si hay paz
podemos caminar cualquier distancia sin
ningún problema en el camino
mientras Yuba rebosa de emoción soldados
fuertemente armados patrullan las
concurridas calles adornadas con
pancartas y carteles de Bienvenida al
pontífice una señal de la importancia
simbólica de esta primera visita papal a
Sudán del sur un país que nunca ha
conocido la paz desde su independencia
en 2011 asolado por una Sangrienta
Guerra Civil de 5 años la nación
predominantemente Cristiana sigue en
plena transición política muchos fieles
esperan que la visita del pontífice
sirva de catalizador y ayude a impulsar
un proceso de paz en las últimas
vienen con un mensaje de amor un mensaje
de paz un mensaje de Reconciliación y el
mensaje de unidad para el pueblo de Dios
en este país
en 2019 un año después del fin de la
guerra civil el Papa Francisco recibió a
salvair y riek machar en el Vaticano el
pontífice se arrodilló y besó los pies
de los dos en un gesto simbólico de paz
y reconciliación